hello I'm Jessie waters along with
Martha McCallum Juan Williams Dana
Perino and Greg Gutfeld it's five
o'clock in New York City and this is the
five
[Music]
Fox News Alert a lot of breaking news to
tell you about Attorney General Jeff
Sessions resigning at president Trump's
request the president already naming
sessions is chief of staff Matthew
Whitaker as Acting Attorney General
sources telling Fox News that Whitaker
is now in charge of everything at the
DOJ including the Russia investigation
this resignation follows president
Trump's a news conference today where he
was repeatedly asked about sessions and
the Muller investigation can you give us
clarity sir on your thinking currently
now after the midterms about your
attorney general and your Deputy
Attorney General do they have long term
job security good answer that a little
bit different time we're looking at a
lot of different things including cabin
I'm very happy with most of my cabinet
you consider removing mr. Muller from
his position I could have ended it
anytime I wanted I didn't and there was
no collusion
we'll have our reaction to this breaking
news and to the president's epic clash
with the media later in the show
but first to our top story the historic
midterm elections Democrats retaking the
house but Republicans making key gains
in the Senate President Trump calling
the outcome a major success Carlos
chabela mike coffman do bad Mike
Mia love gave me no love and she lost
too bad sorry about that Mia and Barbara
Comstock was another one I mean I think
she could have won that race but she
didn't want to have any embrace those
are some of the people that you know
decided for their own reason not to
embrace all right the president also
slamming Republicans would you just saw
who lost for not backing his agenda
fully I thought it was a very close to
complete victory I want Georgia
President Obama campaigned very hard in
Georgia Oprah Winfrey campaigned very
very hard all over the television I said
this is going to be tough I only had me
and then we went to Florida
and they had celebrities all over the
place and a man who happens to be a very
smart person was running Ron de santis
and people didn't give him a chance and
I went and we had we did some great work
you liked how I set those sound but I do
want to make sure everybody knows I
basically nailed my prediction the night
before I said the house the Democrats
were gonna pick up twenty to twenty
eight seats right now they're at 26 I
said in the Senate they're gonna gain
four they've gained three so I'm
basically a genius going to you though
Greg yes a lot of big wins for
Republicans in the Senate and key
governor races but they did lose the
house I don't think you could get a
better outcome than this for president
Trump yeah I want to say I'm kidding
but today is it's about teaching
liberals a lesson about losing nobody
this morning was out setting fire to a
car because they lost the house nobody
was hitting someone in a resistant shirt
in the face cuz they lost the house I
went to the gym that's what that's what
conservatives do they just get on with
their life buff today thank you very
much and I'm really actually and I'm
really happy for the Democrats and I
think it I think because I think it's
important to share power and I don't
think they would I don't they may not
feel that way
but I think it is good for them to have
a voice in government and it and it
granted it's the house I mean who cares
but but it I think it's good news and
also the people that won aren't crazy
progressives
in the suburbs a lot of them are
veterans and the ones that lost a lot of
them like bado and and a few other
people were progressive so that's good
so the good news is the the dams get the
house so the kids get to play with the
toys the Republicans get the Senate so
the adults handle the heavy machinery
and it creates a whole new storyline for
us for us in the media it's like your
favorite sitcom getting a new neighbor
right it's like it's it's like so now
you have a whole new thing the nemesis
it's like the Six Million Dollar Man
when they brought in the Bionic Woman
it's great it's we have so much more
information Martha you're staring at me
like I'm crazy
[Laughter]
Martha you you basically took us down to
the wire last night very late you saw it
and right out right out of the gate into
the very end and you don't seem tired at
all but what's your takeaway from last
night you know I think that what we
ended up with is a map that looks like
America America is very divided you now
have a house that is dominated by the
Democrats and that's going to change
things dramatically they're already sort
of chomping at the bit to get their
hands on a number of these committee
leadership switch is going to I think
you know one of these I think is very
interesting this morning is that you
know the day after the election it was
sort of that feeling and I'm talking
about the presidential election that you
know you sort of that feeling well oh
wow you know there's an incredible
outcome president Trump won so I guess
this is the new reality and everyone's
just gonna sort of maybe accept this and
the country moves on and you see what
where it goes next but no it was like
BAM right out of the gate and I felt
that way this morning as well watching
the president's news conference this
afternoon you know you sort of felt
after last night okay so maybe things
settle in a little bit you've got you
know divided government which is a very
American reality situation and right out
of the gate we have an incredibly
contentious and then we're gonna talk
about this a little bit more later but
incredibly contentious news conference
and a very clear new reality in America
well looking at Juan's face he doesn't
seem as happy as I thought he would be
considering I mean it was not the blue
wave that a lot of people predicted one
and there were some you know worrying
signs for the Trump campaign about you
know going forward in 2020 but you you
don't seem that that excited about
retaking the house well you know to me I
love the idea as Martha was suggesting
there's a check that the Congress the
house is now a check on the president
right I think that's what the founding
fathers intended with our form of
government I embrace that I think it's
terrific but with regard to the blue
wave I feel more like I got Purple Rain
because I was so disappointed by what
happened with the governor and got the
Democratic governor that would have been
the first black governor of Florida or
Stacey Abrams who still in a contest in
Florida I think lots of Democrats were
heavily emotionally as well as
financially invested in bethe O'Rourke
in Texas that came close so to me it was
terrific in terms of looking at the
House races and as I say the big news is
that Democrats now control the house so
when Greg says that's really good news I
was so pleased to hear my friends say
that but I think that it's big news in
part because it's changed the political
landscape that where you had one-party
rule in our country for the last two
years you now have Democrats in position
not only to act as a check but to
participate in terms of the legislative
process ideas and policies in ways that
we have grown unaccustomed to but I just
come back to the idea that when we have
such a divided country it's dangerous I
think there are a lot of feelings and
and I'm just disappointed and you know I
would have liked a stronger sort of
signal to President Trump that people
don't like the divisive rhetoric and the
anger and the kind of things he does and
you look at it and the results are that
women especially white women in the
suburbs went for the Democrats the
independents went for the Democrats well
in rural America President Trump had a
very successful political strategy right
which is I don't care about the suburbs
I only care about my base and I'm going
out and I'm talked to the biggest red
bass and get them culture wars and
migrant invasions and they bought it
that's a shock to me well I mean the
president Dana does have a lot of work
to do in the Rust Belt in Pennsylvania
and Wisconsin in Michigan there's some
warning signs there and in the suburbs
and obviously health care played a major
role in the Democrats victory how do you
see it I think all of that is true I was
really interested in the deepening
divide not just partisan wise but
geographically so rural America versus
urban America and if you look at the big
map right there's red all the way across
in all the rural areas the Republicans
are so strong there but in the cities
those big major population centers
including in Texas Austin San Antonio
Houston Dallas and those are growing
cities that Republicans are gonna have
to keep an I'm thinking twenty years
ahead down the road you got to think
about that Republicans usually had one
the suburbs for a couple decades and to
cede that ground to Democrats is what do
you think that signals policy wise or is
it more about the president's style well
I don't know yet I think that we'll have
to see how things shake out certainly
health care is a thing but in our voter
analysis it showed fifty percent of
people want to go sort of the
progressive way and fifty percent of the
people like the conservative way so how
do you get those minds to come together
but everyone don't the number one is
that's the great you know what maybe
divided government reduces a divisive
nough sin a country because you know as
a libertarian streak likes the fact that
it just it's self canceling so and
that's good as opposed to one of the
problems I'm sorry one of the problems
about divided government in this
environment is that it doesn't work you
know what we see is that gridlock right
so the ideal first situations where
you've got Republicans the Democrats but
they find things that they agree on and
move forward on I don't want them to
move forward that's the thing as a
libertarian I want it to be stuck in the
mud Road gridlock I'm Pro gridlock but I
just think it's an unbelievable like men
still voted strongly for Trump and
Republican I can't believe women vote
for Democrats women voted by twenty
point yeah for the Democrats I love how
I look at the marriage and the marriage
isn't working
maybe the men can't tell the women that
they're married - yes right now we got
that road